what happens when a desert eagle is  placed into scp-914  assistant researcher ericsson placed one  loaded desert eagle into the clockworks  on the setting very fine the output  produced was one desert eagle with no  visible changes however when held it  would induce schizophrenia symptoms in  the holder in exchange for increased  accuracy and stopping power assistant  researcher ericsson commented it tried  to convince me to shoot darby despite  putting it in a secure storage locker 50  meters from where i am now i i can still  hear it i barricaded myself in my room  until the effect wears off i left a slot  under the door for people to slide in  food and messages